[Music]
so today we are going to speak about the
three topics what we did for the
community and what we what does the
results we have seen and how we
implemented it presently the community
strength is thousand nine hundred plus
and we have around eight organizing
teams in it this is one of the picture
which we taken in one of the one of the
session which is having around one
hundred and seven members in the
permeate up so first we are going to
look into what we did to achieve this
accommodations in eleven months so we
completed some three committee meetups
the committee meetups arranges from
machine learning next extended and
kubernetes and certification topics and
we have three self-study grooves on
various various meter which we conductor
these still study grow groups are going
to be closed groups which is between the
attendees and the facilitators so it's
yes them the committee members to learn
along with the facilitator in the closed
group it is enabling the continuous
learning from the community and before
we start any of the committee's the
community meter we used to conduct the
poll on it so based on the audience
interest of the community members
interest we took up the next chapter and
we'll take it up the next sessions so
this year's to understand the members
interest and proceed further as of now
we would say the our strongest part of
the discussions as of now we have around
a ninety one discussion which is
completed till March and I would be like
it is already crossed a ninety five plus
four now this includes all the
discussion ranging from the sponsorships
and sponsorships job openings and
conference launch pads and challenges
and hackathons so many modes are going
to come so with respect to China
community growth we would say like one
of the discussion is under the key part
which is helping out the attendees to be
more interactive and grow along with the
community
so we added all these four things one is
for the meetups another for discussions
and an others for the poll and we are
still steady groups so how we did all
these things is where the partners so we
are believing on the continuous
development so we keep improving all the
meetups one by one and we used to work
on the pattern of 14 days and famine
days and seven days the 14 days will be
allocated for preparation for the
meet-up and seven days will be allocated
for that evaluation of the meetup on
seven days is by allocating on rolling
of the meetups so we used to have a 14-7
7 cross and we keep improvised on the
meetups from from the day one and from
the day first meetup which we have seen
on the next 9 X 2 18 and if you're going
to see the present meter but there is a
continuous they always shows happen we
look into the how the elevation happened
down the line and we are taking some of
the initiative to train our organising
members instead of taking the speakers
from the other communities we are
enabling the company improving the
competency of the organising team so
presently we have obviously data inside
the communities for machine learning
data scientist and kubernetes this is to
continue the continual meet up in very
different way and enable the continuous
learning and we believe we doing the one
channel communication we used to have
all the communication on the meetup page
and we don't we don't have any other
channel this help certainty is to more
come into the meat of Channel and try to
see what was happening in the community
and how this was happening and they
interacting the other thing and as we
said we already have steady groups on it
so what are the feedbacks which we are
getting from the steady growth we are
enabling that and we are putting into
the next Meetup and what are the
speaker's they achieved it and they are
going to have a speaker talks in the
next Meetup
and we show that some of the quick codes
and course there are things to the
meetup person beat up attendees for this
enables them to learn continuously on
the process of it
so we would say like we are utilize all
the tools on the meetup.com from the
pole to discussion to photos and the
discussion and the meetups so we enabled
all the meetups tools which is helps to
roll out get the port full potential of
the platform and in the meetup comm we
have a showcase page so all the
achievers have how the all the meetup
members have access to that they will
post the certification and achievements
on the meetup page and sorry it will
helps to showcase the showcase
achievements or the meetup members to
the external world and other
organization through that some of the
some of the members has got the job
opportunities and other things the job
position opportunities out there so what
are the achievers we are doing it so
achievers will used to have a talk on
the upcoming meetups and based on the
upcoming meetups they used to have a
talk on what have been achieved and this
is motivates the other team other
attendees or other community members to
achieve more on that and we used to
guide on learning paths and how this was
how the certification can be achieved or
how the competency can be achieved and
we used to work with the other
communities in an around of Chennai from
kubernetes and open scripts we used to
work with the other communities inside
and Chennai and which enable the
collaboration between the communities so
here comes a result
so as I said we started this community
before 11 months so we started on the
May 2018 and Jenna Julie Tuesday 18 when
I was presenting the starting my
chapters on next 18 the committee
strength was 250 and presently we have
our own thousand nine hundred members I
think it is already crossed it will be
crossing the two thousand before I close
the next 19 so it is growing at the rate
of 9 members buddy so this is one of the
fasters we are the one of the fastest
committee which is growing in its fear
of all the things what we are doing it
for the community okay
so we already completed someone six
meetups on this lovin months you have to
care of we take a initial break on
understand what is the communities and
what is the platform on how we are going
to utilize so it came out very good we
come data around the six meetups and all
the meters I would say like we are on
more than 4.5 plus rating and it just
indicates the quality of our
deliverables to the community audience
and it is giving a more of fruitfulness
and what we are getting out of the
community so this is the sum of the
atchoo such achievement is made by the
community members so from the even for
the warden th team and the organizing
team they did someone some of the
achievements so the archer are among the
31 achievements from ranging from cloud
certification specialization and courses
and quick laps I know the counters
already modified now because I was
prepared this on March 2019 so I think
it is already crossed 40 we look into
that what is what is those achievements
and on
so this is our community page where we
will have all the meetup discussion was
happening on it so we used to have this
is where we started it
this is our first meetup which was
happened on next c18 extended on July
July August so if you see the condition
if you see the content of it we have put
some of the agenda and we put some of
the description so if you see the next
one which we are going to have it on the
next month there is a there is some
different plan okay so we a complete
around the six meetups and we started
this is how the first meter was happened
we put some of the things after we did
be used to update it so now we are
putting a plan for our our own sales and
says that this is a plan for it on 31st
of March we are going to start the event
and the 14th of April that is a closing
of finish x19 we're going to roll out
the recession closure and we are going
to have we going to have a evaluation so
this helps to reduce some of the
questions from the attendees and we can
work productivity really on our one okay
so these are the some of the things
which is going to happen so we as we
said to be a keep improvising it from
the meetup one we just keep improvising
from the meetup one and the meet of 2
meter 3 and meter 4 meter 5 ok so
as I said we have some of the
achievements right so I'm just rolling
out some of the achievements so these
are some of the achievements made by the
committee members who was completed they
these are some of the members who's from
the volunteers team who's completing the
machine learning then other things all
are from the organizing team in the
volunteer teams and from the community
members
so these are some of the achievements
which we are doing of
so this includes some of the students
who's achieving the machine learning
specialization and it includes the
professionals who are doing it so this
this committee was how the diversified
person from the sets call us to the
student so we are enabling the learning
score for google cloud on the for the
entire portfolio of the scope
as we said we are utilizing most of all
the tools in the meetup.com so this is
one of the showcase tool which is
already available on the meter calm
which we say like if Syria achieved a
quite good
you can go to the respective URL so to
see much more amend which we are doing
it you are continuously doing this
achievements and we collaborating with
all the members so I take this
opportunity to thank all the
organization which is supporting us
including my own organization who's
supporting the work-life balance and as
well as all the sponsors who's helping
on providing the venues and other thing
to run the meetups and be here as I told
we have eight members organising team
ranging from Aishwarya you know the me
and we have Naveen and we have a we have
Naveen Vice navies and Vice Navy we have
strany and we have a couple and comedy
so I take this opportunity to thank all
of them without them I I don't think I
would have achieved this goal in it and
they not been a not able to make it here
but they are been through me here and
I'm taking this opportunity to thank all
my volunteers teams and attendees were
being there and thank you so much for
listening this I hope you had a very
good insight and what is happening in
the community you can check out the link
for more information so we have a chat
was enabled with all the organizing team
you can directly interact with the
organizing team including myself through
the chat if you need any more
clarification on it the same link so
this is we say like one channel
communication across it you can connect
with us for everyone through this link
[Music]